HELP GETTING TO HIS SEAT BUT
APPEARED TO BE DOING WELL.
CONGRESSMEN AND CIVIL RIGHTS
ACTIVIST JOHN LEWIS SAYS THE
CANCER DIAGNOSIS HAS ONE MORE
FIGHT HE WILL TAKE ON.
CORRESPONDED JOHNSON HAS THE
STORY.
>> IS AN ICON OF THE CIVIL
RIGHTS MOVEMENT, DEMOCRAT JOHN
LEWIS HAS NEVER SHIED FROM THE
CHALLENGE AND NOW FIGHTING FOR
HIS LIFE, LEWIS PLANS TO
CONTINUE REPRESENTING GEORGIA'S
FIFTH CONGRESSIONAL DISTRICT
WHILE UNDERGOING TREATMENT FOR
STAGE FOUR PANCREATIC CANCER.
HE EXPLAINED THE PROGNOSIS
DOCTORS TOLD ME THAT RECENT
MEDICAL ADVANCES MADE THE TYPE
OF CANCER TREATABLE IN THE
TREATMENT OPTIONS ARE NO LONGER
AS DEBILITATING AS THEY ONCE
WERE AND THAT I HAVE A FIGHTING
CHANCE.
FORMER PRESIDENT BARACK OBAMA
TWEETED "IF THERE'S ONE THING I
LOVE REPRESENTATIVE JOHN LEWIS,
IT'S HIS INCOMPARABLE WILL TO
FIGHT.
IF I KNOW HE'S GOT A LOT MORE OF
THAT LEFT IN HIM.
OF" A FIGHTER IS HOW COLLEAGUESO
OF" A FIGHTER IS HOW COLLEAGUESN
BOTH SIDES OF THE AISLE CALL HI
HIM.
THEY CALLED FOR GUN CONTROL.
>>
IT TWO DECADES BEFORE THE
ELECTION TO CONGRESS IN 1986, HE
SUFFERED A FRACTURED SKULL AND
THE BLOOD HE SUNDAY MARCH ACROSS
ALABAMA BRIDGE WHICH HELPED TO
GALVANIZE HIS SUPPORT FOR THE
VOTING RIGHTS ACT OF 1965.
>> CONGRESSMAN LEWIS SHOWED A
GREAT LOVE IN THE FACE OF
VIOLENCE AND BRUTALITY.
AND SO WE ARE PRAYING WITH GREAT
COMPASSION FOR CONGRESSMAN LEWI
LEWIS.
THE WARRIOR.
IF I ALWAYS REMEMBER HIM AND HE
HAD
ASD
ASA VERY STRONG WARRIOR.
>> IT WAS ONE OF THE GREATEST
HONORS OF MY LIFE TO WALK BY HIS
SIDE ACROSS THIS BRIDGE AND I
WILL DO THE SAME AS HE CROSSES
HIS NEXT PERIOD >> LEWIS SAYS HE
MAY HAVE TO MISS THE HOUSEBOATS
UNDERGOING CANCER TREATMENT
DURING THE NEXT SEVERAL WEEKS